so donald trump is again defending
golfing this weekend even as multiple
states are hitting
new single-day highs in terms of new
coronavirus cases
and he's defending golfing with a really
strange rant about
how it's his exercise and anyway obama
played more golf which isn't true and
he's getting work done on the golf
course and he's
rushing through the holes anyway so that
nobody should really be mad
it's bizarre but before we get to it
understand the context the context is
trump has spent by one count
277 days on the golf course during his
presidency that's 21.8 percent
of his presidency and of the 277 days
that he golfed
on all but eight meaning 269
he went to courses he owns which is
yet another way in which he has
handsomely profited from the presidency
funneling
taxpayer money your money my money
into his courses by requiring a full
mobilization of government and secret
service
to resorts and golf courses that he owns
so that's one context
the other context is also that donald
trump claimed during barack obama's
presidency
that obama golf too much and that he
wouldn't have any time
for golfing remember some of this stuff
because i'm going to be working for you
i'm not going to have time to go play
golf
i don't have time for that i love golf i
think it's one of the greats but i don't
have time
and i love golf but if i were in the
white house i just
want to stay in the white house and work
my ass off make great deals right
who's going to leave and then even more
specifically because there's a tweet for
everything trump tweeted in october
of 2014 as the ebola
i can't call it a pandemic as the ebola
situation was going on which led to two
deaths
in the united states trump tweeted quote
can you believe that with all of the
problems and difficulties facing the us
president obama spent the day playing
golf
worse than carter so of course trump
golfs
all the time more than obama when not
two but 137 000
americans have died from coronavirus and
he tweets this
bizarre defense of his golfing take a
look at this saying quote
i know many in business and politics
that work out endlessly
in some cases to a point of exhaustion
it is their number one
passion in life but nobody complains my
exercise
is playing almost never during the week
a quick
round of golf obama played more and much
longer rounds no problem
when i play fake news cnn and others
park themselves anywhere they can
to get a picture then scream president
trump is playing golf
actually i play very fast get a lot of
work done on the golf course
and also get a tiny bit of exercise
not bad so does this require analysis
none of it makes sense
he first weirdly starts by saying some
people work out too much and they end up
tired i'm not going to do that now
i don't think anybody mistakenly thought
trump was going to work out so much that
he'd be
he'd be overtired from it i think we
knew that
but he says golfing is actually
his exercise now of course he drives a
golf cart around so the exercise part is
actually pretty limited
walking nine holes with your clubs
walking 18 holes with your clubs it's
really very good exercise
trump doesn't do that but then he adds
in
i'm not playing during the week only on
weekends
but in any case obama golfed more than i
did which is untrue
but in any case he's playing really fast
so he's not spending that much time on
the golf course
and he's getting a lot of work on the
golf course so this is about
four or five different arguments some of
which conflict with
with each other but most importantly he
told us he wasn't going to have time for
golf and these are not normal times we
have a global pandemic which he has
handled worse
than almost anybody uh than any other
world leaders and he's not only spending
time golfing
he's spending time tweeting about
golfing now the counter argument is one
i've made before which is
trump fails at the things he works on so
don't we like
if he golfed all the time maybe
coronavirus
handling would be left to people who are
competent but we know that's not how it
actually works when he's gone
it's that lunatic peter navarro and
you know whoever else it's it's not dr
fauci runs the
show when trump is golfing and putting
aside
the human toll of coronavirus for a
moment that's that's the most important
thing
from a political standpoint many
presidents would have jumped
at a pandemic as a way to secure their
reelection i i've said this before
if donald trump had properly handled
coronavirus if trump said at the
beginning
we are going to do the best on this i am
going to get reelected for
how well i'm going to handle this trump
could have an almost guaranteed
re-election
one of the areas on which biden is
crushing trump the most
is perceptions of handling of
coronavirus if trump had handled that
well
biden would not be leading the way that
he's leading right now trump would need
no
october surprise if he simply managed
this properly
that's mind-blowing to think about
because as usual
trump's problems are mostly
self-inflicted the virus is not
self-inflicted
but look at new zealand right you have
a historically popular leader there
because of how
she dealt with the virus she didn't
cause the virus
but she handled it donald trump hasn't
and it's yet another one of these
partially self-inflicted disasters for
donald trump
this episode is sponsored by blue chew
one of the things i make a priority on
the show is not to perpetuate
stigma for things that don't deserve it
we've talked about mental health we've
talked about many things where we should
all just be respectful adults period and
we would be better off
and blue chew can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for bluetooth.com blue
like the color blue
is the first chewable with the same fda
approved ingredient
as in viagra and cialis it can be taken
day or night
even on a full stomach since it's
chewable it works twice as fast as a
pill
whenever the opportunity arises blue
chew is prescribed online
by licensed doctors you don't have to go
to a doctor's office
you don't have to wait in line at a
pharmacy it ships right to your door in
a discreet package
they're made in the usa and since
bluetooth prepares and ships direct
it's cheaper than a pharmacy and best of
all
no more awkwardness we've got a special
deal for our viewers and listeners go to
bluechew.com
get your first shipment free when you
use our promo code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n
pages five dollars shipping that's blue
chew.com promo code pacman to try it
totally free blue chew is the better
cheaper
faster choice and we thank them for
sponsoring the david pakman show